This September global business and political leaders meet in Dalian in northeast China to ponder how to revive economic growth.
While government stimulus programmes are critical in the near term,
entrepreneurship, innovation and technology will drive a transformational recovery for the long term.
This recovery will be directed by a new generation of leaders – the New Champions –
and the World Economic Forum is bringing them together at this “Summer Davos”.
But the key question is
“Will China pull us out of the economic crisis?
Can China be a significant driver in bringing the world economy out of its present recession?
What do you think?
Simply vote in our poll!
And upload your thoughts on video.
Your videos will be shown at the Annual Meeting of the New Champions in Dalian.
We will encourage the leaders gathered to reply to your videos from Dalian.
Thank You!